-We ran into each other
a few months ago
-Oh, yeah.
-...at a restaurant in L.A.
-Do you remember that?
-Of course I remember that.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah. I didn't know.
-Yeah.
-I saw you.
-I saw you eating.
You were with your girlfriend
and I thought it'd be funny.
I sent you over...
-An olive.
-...one olive.
-One olive.
-I go, split it, eat it
yourself, whatever you want.
I don't want to tell you how
to eat your olive, yeah.
-Yeah, and then what did we do?
We sent you something.
-No, I'll tell you exactly
what you did.
You had the whole restaurant
come over and sing me
happy birthday.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, yes.
-And it's not my birthday.
-Yes.
-It was not my birthday at all.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I blew out the candle.
It was not my birthday at all.
-It was not your birthday.
-It was not my birthday,
but that really made me laugh.
[ Cheering ]
That was good. But then
here's the best move.
You were leaving.
-Yes.
-There was a great guy
who plays music, guitar,
at the -- at the Polo.
-At the restaurant.
[ Laughter ]
-We won't say where it is.
We don't want to give it away.
At the restaurant.
And so he starts singing
"Hey Jude,"
and so I jumped up
to sing with him.
-You did.
-And I thought you were gone.
-Well, no, we were still eating
and you were still singing
"Hey Jude."
[ Laughter ]
And then they do that whole
end part, you know,
where it's just ♪ Ya ♪
-♪ Na, na, na, na, na ♪
[ Laughter ]
-And you just kept going.
It was amazing.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, really.
It was high, low.
-I was harmonizing with myself.
-You were harmonizing.
-But then you --
Were you just leaving?
-Yeah, we were just leaving
and then, you know --
-I grabbed you.
-Your energy, the whole
audience, the audience --
the restaurant was into it
and so, it was just like, let's
all sing, and we all started --
-So we sang "Hey Jude" together.
Yeah, it was fantastic.
You have a great reputation
by the way, in Hollywood
of being a very nice guy,
and I will say,
you always have been nice.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Always have been a cool guy
with me.
-Fix my shirt.
Fix my tie.
-Yeah.
You've always been great to me.
But I saw this photo
that just --
everyone was talking about it
on the Internet.
You crashed someone's wedding
in London.
-I didn't crash their wedding.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it looks like
you weren't invited.
I don't know.
-I sort of look like that.
-I don't know if you crashed it,
but you definitely weren't--
-I was invited to meet some
folks and take a photo.
-Oh, sorry.
So you heard that people
were getting married
or something?
-No. It was outside
and there was another part
of the hotel
and it was outside of London
and they were having a wedding
and then the groom came by
and he was like, "Hi,"
and I was like, "Hi!"
And then he was like,
"Do you want to take a picture
with everybody?" And I said,
"Yeah, sure, let's do it,"
and meet some folks and then we
went in there and I said hi
and hi and hi and then we took
some photographs and that's one
of the photographs.
-It made their night.
-One of these things does not
belong and it was me.
[ Laughter ]
-I would've sang "Hey Jude" with
them, if they asked me, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It was really lovely.
It was cool.
-It's cool that you
do that stuff.
-Nice fun.
Also, it's also cool that you do
this stuff, too.
Can we talk about "Brzrkr"?
-Oh, you have "Brzrkr."
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, yeah, I have "Brzrkr."
-It's a comic book.
-This is unbelievable.
Now, this is just an idea
that you had and you go,
"I'm just going to make this."
-Yeah, I cowrote it
with Matt Kindt
and amazing illustrator
Ron Garney.
Issue 12.
It's a 12-issue limited series.
The last one came out yesterday.
-Yeah.
Do you know the first --
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
-The first issue sold
over 650,000 copies, making it
the highest selling indie comic
of the 21st century.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow. Thanks.
Thanks, universe.
-Wow!
-Thanks, everybody.
No, it's cool.
I love comic books,
and having the chance
to do something like that
was really,
really special.
-How did you end up coming up
with the storyline
and everything?
-Where do ideas come from?
[ Laughter ]
-I know, yeah,
that's a very deep question.
-Where do they --
it came to me -- What about
a character that could punch
people through the chest?
[ Laughter ]
And then, like, what if they
were half God, half immortal?
And then what if they were alive
for 80,000 years?
Then what would society do
with that
but then he's cursed
with violence.
-He doesn't want to be violent.
-No, but it's in his blood.
-He can't die.
Then he doesn't know
who his father is.
-Are you kidding me?
-There's this tribe that like
asks the gods for a weapon
because they're being like
ambushed and exploited
every season.
And then they get this kid --
-When are we seeing this movie?!
[ Cheering ]
I want to see this! Come on!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, and then he's like
being used
by the United States government.
They're trying to like figure
him out, how does he tick.
-Yeah, of course the government
gets involved, yes!
-Of course. Yes!
-Black ops.
-But what would you do
with this idea, Keanu Reeves,
if you couldn't have
this outlet?
Would this just live
in your brain?
[ Laughter ]
I don't know. You did it.
-Yeah, I don't know.
-You got it out.
-I don't know.
I mean, it's like
the creative act
is something special.
-It is, yeah.
-And it's storytelling.
And what would I do
if I couldn't do that?
I'd probably be on the street,
just babbling.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Would you make this
into a movie?
-Yeah, that'd be fun.
-Yeah.
Would you direct it?
-Mm. I don't know.
I don't know.
We tried to shop it around
and then Netflix said,
"Hey, do you want to make it
with us?"
And I was like, "Sure."
And then so we're going to try
and make that happen.
-Whoa!
-Yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I love it.
We have to talk
about "John Wick: Chapter 4."
Buddy, you did it again.
It's unbelievable!
It's -- This one --
This one's the best.
-What?
-This one is the best one.
Yes!
-The best? What?
-Plug your ears because I know
they're all your babies.
But I like this one.
-What? That's awesome.
-The first one was like,
"Holy moly."
-I know,
"What the heck is that?"
-I loved it. I didn't know
the first one was even out.
I don't know how I even saw
the first one.
And I go, "Oh, my gosh." I think
I was in a hotel somewhere.
I go, "This movie's phenomenal."
-That's kind.
-I call my wife, I go, "You've
got to watch 'John Wick,' man."
This is like I'm in all the way,
man, and we love you,
and the whole Fallons love Keanu
at the house, yeah.
-Oh, thanks, Jimmy.
Well, you celebrate my birthday
when it's not my birthday.
[ Laughter ]
It's great.
This one has got it all.
It looks gorgeous.
-Yeah, it's beautiful.
-It's a work of art.
The action starts maybe
five seconds into it
[ Laughter ]
and doesn't stop until you leave
the theater.
-Yeah, there's a lot of action.
-You're on a horse at one point.
-Yeah.
-Shooting people.
-Well, you know, I'm -- Yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
There's nunchucks.
-Yes, there are.
-Yeah.
There's throwing stars.
-There's --
-Driving.
-By the way.
-Crazy driving.
-Driving scenes with no doors.
-Yeah, yeah.
-No windows maybe at one point.
-They got blown out, too.
[ Laughter ]
-There's just a steering wheel
and wheels, that's all it is.
It's like a go-cart,
by the end of it.
-No, that's an American
muscle car.
I'm like throwing 180s.
-Oh, my gosh!
-Doing John Wick things.
-I read somewhere there's
14 action sequences.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And it's all choreographed
brilliantly.
-Yeah, most of the time.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's always --
Well, I can't say
it's always choreographed.
-Is there improvising ever?
-Yeah, kind of, yeah.
-And does that end well?
No?
-Yes.
No humans were harmed
in the making of this film.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, yeah.
-No, I mean, there's a lot --
the director,
visionary Chad Stahelski,
is very inventive
and he really wants to create
different kinds of environments
or ways in the storytelling
for the action.
-He's got to be a genius
because, I mean, this is
the fourth one and you're still
reinventing new ways.
I go,
"Oh, that shot is gorgeous!
How did you even come up
with that?"
The cars on its side, the lights
hitting you at a certain thing.
-Cinema.
[ Laughter ]
Cinema.
-It feels like cinema.
-Cinema.
It feels like you're
watching -- Yes!
-Cinema.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-What can we say
about "John Wick" and this one
that's not spoiling anything?
Or can I just -- Can we just --
Like I know you want to get out.
Like always.
You don't want to do this.
-I don't.
I'm looking
for my personal freedom.
-Yes!
-You know?
It starts with trying to get
my ring back,
but that doesn't work so well,
so then...
-No.
-...I get a little angry.
[ Laughter ]
But then --
But I'm looking
for my personal freedom.
There's a whole bunch
of new characters
who are opening up the world
of the High Table.
-Who plays Caine?
-Caine is Donnie Yen.
[ Cheering and applause ]
He's a legend.
Hiroyuki Sanada. Rina Sawayama,
who was on your show.
-Rina Sawayama is fantastic.
She was on last night.
-She's awesome.
-It's a crusher cast.
-Shamier Anderson.
So we have The Tracker.
We have Caine, we have Shimazu,
so all of these
different characters.
It's friendship, brotherhood,
father, daughter,
the choices that you make,
rules and consequences,
who are you, man?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow! Come on!
-And here's how it's gonna work.
I'll be asking both of you
animal trivia questions.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And if you answer correctly,
you will receive
a golden retriever puppy.
[ Awws, cheering,
and applause ]
-That's the way it works.
-If you answer incorrectly,
your opponent gets the puppy.
[ Awws ]
And whoever has the most puppies
at the end of the game
[ Awws ]
is the Pup Quiz champion.
Keanu, since you're our guest,
you'll answer the first question
and either win or lose
Mr. Gary Frick Jr.
-Okay.
-What is the only species
of reptile --
-I'm so terrible with this.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait.
He didn't even finish
the question.
-I know. I just know it's just
gonna be a disaster.
-No, come on.
-It's just -- okay, go ahead.
-You're gonna get this one.
What is the only species
of reptile native to Ireland.
Is it, A, snake...
-Come on.
-...B, lizard, or, C, turtle?
Not sea turtle.
C, turtle.
[ Laughter ]
-Native to Ireland.
Okay.
So all of those are kind of,
like, the thing and what's
gonna be the thing,
and then what's the thing that
you don't think it's gonna be,
so you're gonna say turtle.
-Right.
But then you're gonna
change your answer to...
-Uh, uh, lizard.
[ Laughter ]
-Lizard. Yes!
Lizard is correct!
[ Cheering and applause ]
You win Gary Frick Jr.
-Hey, buddy.
How's it going?
-Come on.
This is not fair.
First of all,
I'm not taking a puppy
away from John Wick.
[ Laughter ]
Just saying that right now.
-Okay.
This next question's for you,
Jimmy.
-Okay.
-Where you going?
-Which of the following species
is not the name
of a real animal?
Okay?
Which of the following
is not the name
of a real animal species?
[ Awws ]
Is it...
[ Laughter ]
-Let's go see what he's going
to do.
[ Laughter ]
-The following is not the name
of a real animal species.
I think it's
sarcastic fringehead.
-Sarcastic fringehead.
Is that your final answer?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-It is?
-No!
Answer was shorty bobbit.
Oh, shorty bobbit.
[ Ohhs ]
Now, Keanu wins the adorable
puppy Mary Kennedy.
-Oh.
Do they know each other?
Do the puppies know each other?
Is this, like, a common litter?
-We have like
50 puppies backstage.
[ Laughter ]
-You got Gary and Mary.
[ Dog barking ]
Oh, my gosh! Do you hear that?
-No.
-That sound means it's time
for Double Puppardy.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Double Puppardy?
-Questions are now worth
two puppies.
[ Laughter ]
-Watch out.
-Keanu.
-What?
-A dik-dik...
[ Laughter ]
Is it...
Not cantaloupe.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. So, you do the one
that you think it's gonna be,
but then you pick the one that
you don't think it's gonna be,
and then you pick the one that
and then the dik-dik
is an antelope.
-That is correct!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Are you out of your mind?
-Keanu, you and Lisa McAdams
and Lisa Armstrong.
-Double Puppardy.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Wow!
-Let's go, Fallon.
-Come here, boy.
That's it. Come here, boy.
That's a good boy.
-It's puppy love!
-You give that one back --
-That's my puppy, Fallon!
-I love it.
-Alright, next question
goes to Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
Is it...
Down to fetch.
-Maybe, uh, B?
-No, it's to tell other dogs
they are tall!
[ Sad tuba ]
So, Keanu, you get Roger Blaine
and Ted Mooney!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Can you help the dogs?
-Yeah.
-Hi.
Who's the puppy king?
-C'mere.
There you go.
-I'm the puppy king!
-There we go.
You got 'im.
Alright.
[ Laughs ]
-Hey, buddy.
-Okay.
[ Dog barking ]
Oh, my gosh!
That sound means it's time
for Final Puppardy.
This is for all your opponent's
puppies and the game.
So pick up your iPads
if you can.
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
You'll have 10 seconds
on the clock starting now.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-They left, they left.
They just left.
They left.
-Oh!
-They left, okay?
They're wandering --
[ Buzzer ]
It's chaos.
I'm gonna say 10.
-Keanu, what did you write down?
-Uh, 6, but if it's not 6,
then it's a 9.
[ Laughter ]
-The answer is 6!
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There we go.
-My thanks to Keanu Reeves,
these adorable puppies.
Stick around! We'll be right
back with Melanie Lynskey!
Congratulations.
-How's it going?
-Yeah. bud, c'mere.
[ Cheering and applause ]